My daughter is losing hair. Dr. said it was from COVID. He told us to use L methyl folate.
We also made the hair remedy you mentioned on your site, lavender rosemary, etc.
My head started itching and so are two more of my kids. I assume that your head started itching
from the lavender rosemary, you need lady to water it down a little bit more with a
carrier oil, if that's true. The loss of hair also, I don't think methyl tetrahedral folate
is really going to be the cure for loss of hair. The other thing you want to look at is
how it may have affected thyroid. If there's a decrease in thyroid T3,
T4 production, then you could end up with hair loss. That's one of the symptoms of low
thyroid. If you do a thyroid test, you want to make sure that you are requesting from your doctor
a complete thyroid profile because many times they'll just do a TSH test and many times they'll
do a TSH, a T3 and a T4. That's still inadequate. You need to get three T3, three T4
and reverse T3 because many times T3 is made and then it's a flip cis isomer of T3 which
can never flip back to the usable T3. Your thyroid makes T3 and T4. T3 is the active form of the
hormone but 94, 95% of thyroid hormone is released as T4 and then it's turned into T3 in the gut
and in the liver. It can be turned into reverse T3 and then a person can have normal TSH and slightly
low T3, slightly low T4 and really elevated reverse T3 and that's really their problem.
Then you also want to look and make sure that the person doesn't have
Hashimoto's and you test for TPO antibodies. That is a more complete
a thyroid panel that you'll want to ask for so you want to write that down so that's what you're
asking for. You want to measure her thyroid